hi Brittany my name is David Catching  Fire is my favorite Hunger Games book -  I think we'd be really compatible  together I'm never gonna get laid  dude stop overthinking it just send out  a bunch of messages man somebody's gonna  respond do you want to like come in and  try a minute yeah I should drink up my  parents are dying to meet you you're  getting my bell a - right oh let's go  cowboy I'm driving sorry the place is  such a mess my boyfriend's in New York  I can speak feline cats love me this is  a tinder date why are we getting coffee  hey David I consider myself a Hufflepuff  - maybe we could get coffee sometime  all my pictures are from a year ago  she's not going to Who I am you look the  same you look like the exact same